Welcome to lesson two everybody. In this lesson we're going to learn
about forms. Forms you've seen all over the place on the internet.
They're the text boxes, check boxes, radio buttons that basically allow
websites to get information from users, including on [UNKNOWN] own site. Every
quiz you do is submitting a form. So we are going to
spend a lot of time, basically learning how to build this things
in your editor in a browser testing them out. And we're
also going to spend time learning how to make sure the data you're
getting from the user is actually secure. Because this is
how you let the users basically into your website. So
we have to make sure that we only allow them
do what we want them to do. So, let's get started.